- As it seems to happen every few months,
certain politicians are making a big stink
about section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act.
The funny thing is, that
if they were successful
in repealing section 230,
it would be disastrous
for those politicians
because it does two things.
Number one, it allows
platforms to moderate.
And number two, it provides a shield
so that if a user posts something,
the platform isn't
responsible for that post.
And while a lot of people
are mad about the moderation,
If that shield was destroyed,
a lot of those accounts,
the ones that are at risk,
that are peddling conspiracy theories
and are possibly defamatory,
would be simply shut down.
The first one to be shut down?
Probably President Trump's.
So as the old proverb says,
be careful what you wish for.
I did a whole video on this
in the past, check it out.
And if you liked this video,
check out my other Eagle Briefs
where I cover the legal issues of the day.
And as always, I'll see you in court.